[Musique]
I'm buck Ferguson l'épisode de ce soir
ne concerne pas seulement le fait de tuer le
cerf de Virginie, il s'agit aussi de la famille hey buck
je vais le chercher fais comme chez toi
fais moi comme chez moi prêt à aller tuer
ton premier cerf de Virginie  tu sais que
ce ne sera pas la plus grande vidéo que
nous ayons jamais faite
, je ne peux pas croire que tu es sur ton
premier appel de cerf Caroline père
enseigne à leurs fils à chasser comme un rite de
passage aussi vieux que le temps Je vais
je me considère toujours plus comme un gars de Marriott
le soleil quand tu vois ton premier
cerf de Virginie ça va avoir l'air tout
mignon et moelleux nous pouvons honorer le cerf
mais nous ne pouvons pas l'aimer panini à la dinde les
paninis sont de bonnes bosses sur le cerf un
cerf
[  Musique]
tu sais pourquoi j'aime ces bois ici
il n'y a rien pour me déranger amen
[Musique]
sauve-moi 3 quand tu trouves un cerf
tout se met en place Je ne peux pas
croire que ce moment est ici que la
boutique
[Musique]
il ne  ne prends pas maintenant il ne peut jamais
pourquoi enregistrez-vous cette aube cela fait partie
du nar  Rative, je craignais juste que cela ne
fasse une bonne crise à mi-chemin ou n'augmente les
enjeux de la caméra commencée à l'aube en essayant
d'avoir un moment avec mon fils, maman
et Greg ont dit que je pouvais me calmer, tu as
appelé papa Greg ouais mais seulement comme cinq
fois la première fois  J'ai rencontré ma petite amie,
elle est comme si j'étais un mécanicien certifié, une
infirmière autorisée, je suis comme oh ouais eh bien
devinez ce que j'ai eu un camion cassé dans un
problème cardiaque
vous et moi avons fait des choses dont la règle
va se souvenir Je pense que c'est probablement la
couverture la plus  de ce truc de l'autre
côté du pont là tu veux que je
traverse le pont en premier donc je suis couvert
de toi testant le pont avant que
quelqu'un ne le traverse à cause d'un coffre-fort
exactement ne t'inquiète pas j'ai
oh Jésus
toi